it's minus seven degrees Celsius in
Moscow but that doesn't stop the amateur
football team a la bouche Eva they play
at least once a week no matter what the
weather
Alexander murican has been playing with
the team for two years he's a school
sports teacher but on and off the pitch
soccer has always been his passion here
in Russia football is the game of the
people strike shoot beautiful goals we
may not be at the World Cup but we
definitely try to play an elegant game
over 700,000 tickets to the World Cup in
Russia have already been sold so far
about half of them have gone to the
country's own fans including Alexander
there are reminders of the upcoming
event dotted across Moscow even a
countdown to the kickoff and the
majority of Russians feel positive about
hosting the World Cup this coming year
while it's in the car yes though it's a
good thing of course a lot of tourists a
lot of guests will come we're always
happy to have guests would you it's a
serious major event and I know that a
lot of people are already buying tickets
online people here are definitely
looking forward to the World Cup
national tour the World Cup has given a
boost to the infrastructure of cities
like rostov-on-don Nizhny Novgorod
Saransk and wonderful stadiums have been
built now the guests just have to arrive
avoid noise dome gusty the city of
Moscow has been feverishly preparing as
well investing one and a half billion
euros to improve pedestrian zones and
roads
in cooperation with FIFA the city has
even given one of its metro trains a
makeover it will be spreading the soccer
spirit across Moscow until the end of
the World Cup but Alexander and his
teammates won't be needing any
encouragement when it comes to the
soccer spirit today they're watching a
game at a teammate's local bar Alex Sun
that has been an avid football fan since
he was six he'll of course be backing
his home team at the World Cup and we'll
be watching the draw closely we're the
hosts so the main thing is for us to at
least come first or second in our group
we hope that the Russian team will end
up in an easy group the whole country is
hoping for an easy group gesture on an
idea it's my local group on the Russian
national team currently is the lowest
ranked of all the World Cup participants
but no matter who wins fans like
Alexander can still enjoy a month of the
beautiful game